іноземні
[Оплески]
[Музика] [
Оплески] [
Музика] [Музика
] [
Музика]
це [
Музика] [Музика]
доброго ранку, шановні колеги, вітаємо
фінальну конференцію програми навичок eufo,
я думаю, ви повинні бути щасливі бути тут
разом  у цьому прямому ефірі
та мати можливість спілкуватися просто для того, щоб
нагадати вам для тих, хто цього потребує, у вас
є гарнітури на ваших столах,
дякую, так,
я Наталя Барсінкова, я буду
модератором
цієї події сьогодні,
і ми також проводимо онлайн-трансляцію
на YouTube
I  Я впевнений, що у нас є практично
всі, хто професійно займається
розвитком ветеринарної медицини
та намагається, щоб він
розвивався далі, щоб відповідати потребам
ринку праці та потребам країни,
ми дуже раді бачити вас сьогодні тут, у
нас також присутні представники профільних
міністерств  та інституції, що працюють над
впровадженням ветеринарної реформи,
представники донорських установ,
які надали свої експертні
знання з об’єктів, ми також маємо представників
відділів освіти та навчальних
центрів з більшості областей
України, тож великі оплески для
всіх
[Музика],
а я не  Випадковий відвідувач, але
також
я керуючий партнер єдиної
агенції охорони здоров’я, і я з гордістю можу повідомити вам,
що наша команда брала участь у
реалізації двох проектів
з точки зору просування відео.
Перший стосувався
просування дівчат-ветеранів, а також  на
боротьбу з ґендерними стереотипами
сприйняття, а другий
стосується тренінгу,
е-е, навчальний курс з професійно-технічної
освіти та навчання, і я бачу, що деякі
люди пам’ятають його,
і це курс, доступний на нашій
онлайн-платформі для ветеринарів, будь ласка, приєднуйтесь,
він справді добре працює, щоб популяризувати це
знову ласкаво
просимо, це наш  Я сподіваюся, що
ви зможете пригадати всі
історії успіху. Я
думаю, що, незважаючи на все, що
зараз відбувається в країні, ми
все ще сильні,
ми стійкі, і зараз у нас є дуже
важливі перспективи,
враховуючи необхідність відновлення та відновлення
країна,
ми дуже вдячні партнерам, з
якими ми працювали протягом усього
часу, коли ви вдосконалювали свої навички,
до речі, у вашому документі є порядок денний цієї події, і ви можете
перевірити час наших
виступів і виступів, а також просто
коротке нагадування про
правила безпеки через воєнний час, у якому ми
живемо,
якщо почнеться тривога щодо швидкості повітря,
усі речі приведуть нас до
притулку, і ми знову зберемося тут після того, як
тривога закінчиться,
я сподіваюся, що
сьогодні у нас не буде такої неприємності,
але  щоб нагадати вам, що нам доведеться
дотримуватися правил щодо усного
перекладу, ми матимемо
спікерів різними мовами, ті, кому
потрібен переклад, ви можете мати
гарнітуру, щоб слухати
подію мовою, яку ви
бажаєте,
це англійська, будь ласка, виберіть
перший канал для  Український канал 2.
з нами також є онлайн-учасники,
і велика їм подяка
за те, що вони приєдналися до
чергових
технічних коментарів, мабуть, останніх
після кожної сесії,
ви знаєте, що ми збираємось проводити
публічні панельні дискусії, щоб обговорити
важливі методи
розвитку кадрового потенціалу ветеринарної медицини
розвитку, і ви матимете можливість
поставити запитання доповідачам,
я пропоную вам використовувати ваші зошити та
ручки,
якщо у вас виникнуть запитання
під час презентації, просто не
забудьте занотувати їх у свій блокнот,
і тоді у вас буде шанс  тож ми
матимемо Артеома, який буде ходити між столами
та збирати запитання аудиту,
і ми докладемо всіх зусиль, щоб передати їх
спікерам, щоб вони відповіли.
Це план на сьогодні,
і я сподіваюся, що це буде
для нас плідний день, надихаючий,
і це буде  зробіть менше шансів на
взаємодію та спілкування для всіх,
тож знову вітаємо цю заключну
конференцію програми навичок НЛО
[Оплески]
пару слів щодо порядку денного,
ну, програма, вибачте,
це програма для підтримки реформи
професійної освіти та навчання в
Україні  це було підтримано ЄС та
Німеччиною, Фінляндією, Польщею та Естонією,
державами-членами ЄС, і ми глибоко вдячні
їм за це,
дякую вам, завдяки вам, це було
успішно фактично реалізовано,
ми на завершальному етапі,
також виконавцями є
організації GSW з
Країни, що співфінансують
Фінська національна освіта та польський
фонд солідарності Duffy
та Harno
Естонія,
головна мета — підтримати
розвиток професійно-технічної освіти та
навчання. Все почалося ще в 2019 році
з основною метою — адаптувати
освітню підготовку та навчальну програму
[Музика],
щоб  поточні потреби, я думаю, що це не
випадково саме в 2019 році,
коли цей процес почався,
я думаю, що тепер ми маємо набагато більш чітке
розуміння того, наскільки це важливо
і наскільки важливий процес
там розгортається для країни
програма мала сім пілотних  нам
потрібна операція Supple Towers
за кордоном.
З початком війни програма
швидко переглянула свої пріоритети,
щоб зберегти, щоб допомогти закладам
зберегти можливість навчання в цих
складних умовах,
і справді було дуже важливо, щоб
програма залишалася гнучкою, і вони зробили
це просто  як це,
ми сподіваємося, що ви змогли відчути
позитивні сторони програми та її
впровадження,
її вплив на студентів ветеринарних шкіл
для викладання.
Я впевнений, що згодом ми побачимо ще
більше,
і ми
почуємо більше  про це,
так, програма була б неможливою
без наших партнерів, і я радий
запросити на цю сцену партнерів
програми молодіжних навичок,
а не представників,
я називатиму ваші імена та запрошуватиму
вас на цей
подіум для менш формальної
презентації, пан Фредерік Куна, голова
співпраці нова делегація в Україні
Елізабет Мюллер прийняла радника з питань освіти
Посольства Німеччини
Метро Родні Заступник міністра
освіти і науки України
пан Даніель Буше Jazz at Ukraine
country director [
Музика]
Роман Паклонський Директор
Департаменту зайнятості Міністерства
Економіка та Ольга Коваль
освіта та
інновації
Wunderbar у
нас дуже гарна, представницька
та сильна група спікерів і
партнерів, тут у вас є ваш Майк, там
учасники,
тому ви можете або Майка з залу,
або підійти ближче до трибуни,
поставити запитання,
і я думаю  було б приємно, щоб
учасники дискусії продовжували сидіти, я б хотів, щоб мене
викинули до Фредеріка Корнера, голови відділу
співпраці Представництва ЄС в Україні,
дуже дякую,
доброго ранку, всім радий вас бачити,
я не збираюся використовувати якийсь
якщо я розуміюся на
математиці, мені
щедро виділили дві з половиною хвилини,
як і іншим людям тут,
так що,
гм,
Павло
Еріна Сумік, так, Віра,
де інші, скажімо, старожили,
які були там чотири чотири з половиною
роки тому
три  міністри тому, які все ще там,
пам’ятайте дискусії, які ми мали, ми
думали, що
нам просто потрібно все розібрати
між giz kfw, ми просто повинні знайти,
ми повинні знайти правильні пілотні школи,
і тоді все піде гладко,
якими наївними ми можемо бути  правильно Багато чого
сталося, тоді ми думали о, ковіт,
жахливий
ковід, вибачте, це було нічого, правильно, прийшла війна,
ми все ще там, все йде.
Україна показала, що вона може продовжувати
свої реформи, що школи є,
реформуються все дуже добре
Я не буду говорити про
досягнуті результати, ви знаєте це набагато
краще за мене, я не буду говорити
про те, скільки грошей дає Європейський Союз
і наскільки ЄС підтримує
Україну, ви чуєте це щодня на  Новини,
що я хочу зробити, це я хочу подякувати
людям, які тут були залучені,
перш за все, звичайно, я хочу подякувати
іншим донорам, які беруть участь, тому
Німеччина Естонія Фінляндія Польща
сподіваюся, що я нікого не пропустив,
я б також  хотів би дуже подякувати всім
виконавцям, тому що було
залучено багато партнерів, тож це не
лише giz та edufi тощо, але й багато
інших людей, які були залучені, і це
було дуже-дуже важке завдання,
хм,
впровадження реформ у мирні часи
надзвичайно складне, це  надзвичайно важко,
ніхто не хоче цього робити,
робити це під час війни – це ще
більше досягнення, тож велике спасибі
за все це,
і, нарешті, я також хочу подякувати
колегам з міністерства, тому що
ви показали велику залученість  у
ці важкі часи,
і я говорю тут не лише про
людей у ​​самому міністерстві, а й про
людей, які опосередковано працюють на
міністерство, вчителів,
тому що хорошим учителем є
не той, хто є найшвидшим, а не
той, хто має  найкращі методології так,
методологія важлива.
Хороший вчитель – це той, хто справді
поруч і виконує свою
місію в житті. Хтось дійсно
вірить, що це його роль
у навчанні наступного покоління,
і я думаю, що за останні пару
років ми  бачив кілька поганих прикладів
людей, які показали, що вони були
там лише тому, що могли заробити гроші
чи щось подібне, але було
багато інших
дуже блискучих випадків, коли люди, які не
завжди звучали залежно від мене,
незважаючи на війну, були там,
щоб підготувати цю молодь  покоління,
щоб підготуватися до
їхньої економічної взаємодії в житті, і
особливо якщо ми зараз дивимося також на
війну, що для реконструкції так,
звичайно, вам знадобляться юристи,
вам знадобляться економісти, але без
сантехніків, без теслів і так далі,
я не зможу мати справу з
вашою реконструкцією, тому я
хотів би подякувати та висловити свою глибоку
повагу всім цим учителям, які
справді виконували свою місію
в житті, навчаючи наступний етап
наступного покоління молодих людей тут
дякую, дякую
[оплески]
ми сподіваємось, що все буде гаразд і завдяки
підтримці велике дякую так,
велике дякую, і ми продовжуємо
я хотів би навчитися міс
Елізабет Міллер освітній радник
у мене є теза для виступу  але не
хвилюйтеся, вони не дуже довгі від імені
посольства Німеччини від імені Німеччини
я хотів би подякувати всім, кому можу повторити те,
що сказав Фредерік, я хочу подякувати
всім донорам Партнерам усім українським
урядовим партнерам, але перш за все  всі
також усі виконавці та всі
люди на місцях у
школах, які справді зробили все,
хто насправді досяг успіху в цій
програмі. Я думаю, це так, без цих
людей це просто неможливо, ви можете дати
багато грошей, ви можете найняти багато людей
але вам справді потрібні люди на
місцях, які створюють хоч один дюйм і творять,
які вірять у зміни та вірять у
реформи, тож дякую вам за те, що
участь Німеччини в Т розпочалася ще в
2017 році, тоді ми вже тоді зосереджувалися
на професійно-технічній освіті внутрішньо переміщених осіб  з
регіону Донбасу,
потім ми об’єдналися з ЄС, ми
об’єдналися з державами-членами ЄС, щоб стати частиною
euful навичок.
70 мільйонів євро
для VT з тих пір, це не про
гроші, це лише про зобов’язання, які
ми маємо для цього важливого сектора в
Україні, тому що ми віримо, що
це справді вирішальний сектор для
розвитку української економіки та
для розвитку української молоді
люди,
гм, я в Україні з
2012 року. На жаль, це мій останній тиждень
в Україні, тому ця програма добігає
кінця, мій час добігає кінця,
мені дуже сумно через це, але, дивлячись у
майбутнє, я  гм, фактично продовжуватиму
працювати над Україною, і я
продовжуватиму працювати над українськими
програмами розвитку навичок, а також
з іншого боку від Німеччини, тому ми
залишатимемося відданими, і дозвольте мені також
сказати вам, що Німеччина вже
профінансувала та створила новий  програма з
розвитку навичок,
у цій програмі знову,
на жаль, ми зосереджуватимемося на
потребах внутрішньо переміщених осіб, на потребах
уразливих людей, які постраждали від війни,
і на способах
інтеграції цих людей також у трудову діяльність.
ринку, і сьогодні я хотів би запросити
всіх наших партнерів. Я хотів би запросити
ЄС і всі країни-члени ЄС
взяти участь у цій ініціативі. Я дуже
чекаю цього нового розділу
нашої співпраці. Дякую,
дуже дякую
дякую за вашу постійну підтримку
України, дякую,
ви можете просто поговорити, я
радий запросити пана Еда Метроса,
заступника міністра, міністра освіти
та науки,
доброго ранку, радий вітати вас,
для мене дуже цікаво бути
тут новачком,
спостерігати
хм заключний захід проекту, який
тривав більше трьох років,
хм,
я відвідав багато місць в Україні,
де люди
постійно розповідали мені про цей проект
і наголошували на своїх планах, що вони
планують зробити для продовження цього проекту, і
я відчув, що  люди дуже вдячні за
результати проекту за його
результати, вони задоволені
ними, тому я хотів би
подякувати всім, хто долучився до
реалізації проекту, перш
за все Ірині, тому що я знаю, скільки
зусиль вона  зробив внесок у проект,
перебуваючи в міністерстві, працюючи в
міністерстві, я мав можливість побачити, скільки
людей працювало над проектом,
для мене дуже важливо, які
позитивні уроки та уроки загалом
ми можемо винести з
реалізації цієї програми,
перш за все  все, що ми
зрозуміли, що запровадження навчальних
центрів професійної підготовки та
закупівля хорошого обладнання для них –
це правильна річ, а також
знову наймання кваліфікованого персоналу для цих навчальних центрів, це дуже
важливо, це позитивний урок,
який потрібно отримати  навчившись
тоді, спробувавши
запровадити
дуальну освіту
та індивідуальну освіту, ми зрозуміли,
які перешкоди існують в Україні, і
що потрібно зробити, щоб подолати ці
перешкоди, і загалом
[Музика]
гм,
ми можемо оцінити цей загальний проект як
дуже успішний проект іноді  в
Україні ми маємо справу з не настільки
успішними проектами, і
в таких випадках люди намагаються
якомога швидше завершити проект і майже
забути про нього, тоді як цей проект
виявився успішним, тому що люди
хочуть продовжувати те, що було розпочато в
ході  і
в той же час ми усвідомлюємо, що
попереду надто багато роботи, і
тому нам потрібна буде ваша
підтримка, ваш внесок у майбутньому, і
я заохочую вас продовжувати працювати над
результатами проекту та збільшувати те, що
ви дізналися та  що ви
представили завдяки проекту,
і я хотів би
використати те, що щойно згадав мій колега
[Музика]
хм,
звичайно, події останніх
кількох років, спочатку пандемія, потім
спалах повномасштабної війни,
вони покращують стійкість  людей
мене дуже вразило,
водночас е-
е,
я чітко розумію, що ми
не повинні виправдовуватися через
пандемію через війну і
пояснювати, що ми не можемо зробити це, ми не можемо зробити
те через це виправдання, але ми
розуміємо, що є  надзвичайні ситуації,
як-от IDPS, як-от
люди, яким потрібна допомога та допомога, але
я не думаю, що ці надзвичайні випадки
повинні завадити нам від бажання
покращити систему освіти
загалом, загальну
освітню систему, тому що
внесок усіх доступних ресурсів
у заходи порятунку, тому що
це не  дасть стійкий
довгостроковий результат, тому що якщо він займатиметься
боротьбою з пожежами просто зараз, так би мовити, тоді
ці люди будуть або, можливо, більше
зацікавлені
мігрувати з України в пошуках кращих
умов, якщо ми не зможемо
забезпечити стійкі
умови для тривалої роботи та
освіта, дякую
[оплески]
Я хотів би запросити вас до
мікрофона, пане Даніель Буше, гізет,
регіональний директор в Україні,
гм, доброго ранку, вітаю, а
також дякуємо іншим спікерам, присутнім
на панелі, які, е-е, як би
продовжують свою роль, ви розумієте
багато  речі, які ви планували
сказати, уже згадувалися, але
дозвольте мені скористатися нагодою, щоб розширити те, що
я почув від імені GSAT як
виконавця програми, тому я думаю,
що ви щойно сказали з точки зору
довгострокових зобов’язань  на шляху до реформування та свого
роду стратегічної мети
програми, водночас залишаючись
достатньо гнучким, я вважаю, що це один із
факторів успіху та ключових факторів
також цієї програми з точки зору досягнення
результатів у довгостроковій
перспективі  але також щодо більш короткострокових
і середньострокових впливів, які я вважаю справді
вражаючими, і коли я прийшов на борт, і
ми також дізнаємося про програму, я
думаю, що це також те, що
демонструє відданість команди,
яка це зробила
і тому я просто хотів би також висловити
велику подяку групі
реалізаторів, які фактично зробили це
можливим разом із партнерами, тому
гнучкість, на мою думку, є ключовою і
залишатиметься ключовою, не випускаючи з уваги
довгострокову стратегічну мету  така
програма,
а в секторі, по-друге, я вважаю, що
ключовим є наявність відданих партнерів,
а також сильних партнерів, які
справді також здатні витримувати ту
стійкість, яка потрібна, про яку ви
згадали, що, на мою думку, також не є
природним даром, але це приходить  з набором
компетенцій, які партнери привносять у
правління і які я також можу побачити тут, і за які
я також глибоко вдячний, і
тоді я б сказав, що останнє, але не менш важливе, і
це було згадано через оренду, але також
рух вперед також, звичайно,
щось приємне на
закритті, і в першу чергу я хотів би
аплодувати та привітати
всіх, щоб справді відбулася така подія.
Завжди трохи дивно та
особливо бути на церемонії закриття
та озиратися назад, якщо у вас немає
можливість чекати з нетерпінням, і хоча я
дуже ціную такі моменти, як цей
тут, і вони стали трохи рідкісними
під час таємних часів, а також під час війни,
давайте будемо чесними, тому я вважаю, що
такі особисті зустрічі
та збори, а також святкування потрібні
успіхи, це навіть більше, тому я б сказав, що
надихає дивитися вперед, і те, що
Лісабон згадував від імені
уряду Німеччини щодо
навичок для Відновлення, я думаю, також
безпосередньо переживає досягнення, я б
сказав, мети, яка, я думаю,
також дуже дорога  до
роботи GSD як такої, я щойно був на
Лондонській конференції минулого тижня, де,
ймовірно, багато хто з вас також були,
стежили за заголовками, і
хоча ви бачите всю
політичну прихильність на високому рівні щодо
відновлення та реконструкції, ви  цікаво,
хто збирається це робити, і Фредеріку,
ти щойно згадав, що герої
в касках електрики,
сантехніки, будівельники вони
також потрібні, тож я справді чудовий для
цих навичок для Відновлення, ми
розглянемо це, і я  Я щасливий, що ми,
як генеральний директор, зможемо зробити такий внесок.
Дуже дякую, з нетерпінням чекаю події, дякую, дякую,
і тепер я радий дати мікрофон,
щоб пропустити Рамана Пакланського з
Департаменту професійної освіти
міністерства  ну дякую разом
із Metro я приєднався до проекту La
Rada на пізньому етапі, коли він майже
наближався до фіналу, і
усвідомлюючи
важливість проекту. Я
хотів би подякувати Німеччині та Фінляндії,
Естонії та Польщі за реалізацію цього проекту,
і я  хотів би використати
цю можливість, щоб просувати реформу
праці та ринку праці, яку
планує міністерство економіки цими днями.
Я не нова
людина в міністерстві економіки, я
раніше працював у департаменті
навколишнього середовища та природних ресурсів у складі
те саме міністерство, а зараз я працюю в
Департаменті праці, і я хотів би
нагадати вам, що у нас є
департамент зайнятості, і через цей
департамент ми
нещодавно зробили внесок у цей проект, ми
збільшили кількість
[музикових]
спеціалістів, яких потрібно навчати  і
двічі перенавчалися за кошти державного бюджету
спеціально думали про ті
навички та професії, які будуть
потрібні для розбудови України
після війни.
бюджет, а це Sabres,
звісно, ​​це, ну,
можливо, сказати, щоб зізнатися, що ми повинні були
запустити таку професію, але
все ж це була вимога
нашого часу, і протягом останніх кількох
років люди досить
ретельно думали, як заробити більше грошей у
інтелектуальних професій або в
професійно-технічних
професіях, і
я вважаю, що ми повинні зробити все
можливе, щоб дозволити
професіоналам
робітничих професій заробляти
гідні гроші,
і тепер я радий дати потік
сумувати Ольга Кабаль з парламенту
України зі свого дому Нарада
України  ну, дякую за цю можливість.
Я останній доповідач на фінальній події.
Мені дуже приємно, що
я зробив це. ну все ж у мене є, ну
я збентежений, що я відчуваю,
насправді
якесь
ностальгічне відчуття, що
ми багато зробили для розвитку  професійне
навчання та освіту та розвиток
людського капіталу в цілому,
водночас я дуже вдячний
усім, хто був залучений до
реалізації проекту, і
я впевнений, що це лише початок
великої роботи, яку ми маємо  попереду
моє коротке
вітальне слово має залишитися
коротким, тому що
протягом усього дня перед нами ми
будемо обговорювати результати проекту, але ми
системно намагалися проводити
кампанію та просувати професійне навчання
та його реформування,
але з ентузіазмом від самого
З початком повномасштабної війни ми відчули
допомогу, і
особливо для внутрішньо переміщених осіб для мене як
законодавця, хм,
поправки до
законодавства є основним застереженням,
як правило,
хм,
внесення поправок до законодавства
непросте, і ЄС за навички
став дуже хорошим партнером у цьому
Я говорю про проект закону про
професійне навчання, і
зараз я впевнений, що дуже
важливий
закон буде остаточно доопрацьований, і я
хотів би подякувати всім, хто
долучився до
реалізації проекту нашим іноземним партнерам
з Європейського Союзу та
Європейського Союзу.  країн до Німеччини, Фінляндії,
Польщі та Естонії, ви наші справжні
партнери. Я хотів би подякувати пані
Шумах, яка є рушієм цього
процесу, і врешті-решт я хотів би
підкреслити, що о,
ми переможемо дуже скоро, і ми повинні
бути готові до перемоги, яку ми  треба бути
готовим до того моменту, коли ми це отримаємо,
щоб почати відбудову країни, дякую, дякую
нашим партнерам, хочу
сказати, що
разом ми сильніші і ми
непереможні, щоб разом ми були
готові негайно відновити Україну
після перемоги ви
надихнули нас, велике спасибі
[Музика]
Я маю на увазі, що ви
озброїли нас, запевнивши,
що це початок дуже
великого процесу, ми дуже цінуємо наших партнерів,
тому що ми знаємо, що ми можемо зробити
все лише разом  команда
тепер давайте
заглибимося в
результати проекту в кінцеві результати
проекту, щоб обговорити, як ми досягли
цих результатів, і
згадати наші
успіхи. Я радий запросити пана
Алексі Алекса шовкового ні, опишу
впровадження проекту, дякую,
доброго ранку,
дорогий  гості, колеги, друзі, експерти,
дозвольте мені запросити вас у коротку сьогоднішню подорож.
Ця подорож називається «ви за навичками та
ветеринарними реформами»,
я скажу це так
протягом цієї подорожі, у цій подорожі
ми змогли зібрати багато
скарбів, які ми б хотіли  щоб поділитися з
вами сьогодні, мова йде про знання,
досвід і наші партнерські стосунки,
і ми хотіли б сьогодні дозволити
собі порекомендувати
продовжити цю подорож.
слайд тут
містить загальну інформацію про два
проекти для навичок, той, який змінив
життя багатьох в Україні, ми  Сподіваюся, що так і
надалі, тому що освіта –
це інвестиції в майбутнє, у
майбутнє нової України,
ми були разом протягом
системних реформ і ми були разом під час
пандемії, під час бажаного
часу
в найкритичніші моменти
повноцінності Росії.  масштаб агресії
в минулому році і зараз, як і наша
служба медична захист
незалежності Королівська країна на
передовій ми боремося за майбутнє
кожного громадянина України або за майбутнє
нашої країни давайте коротко переглянемо
шлях програми, щоб побачити
шлях, яким ми сьогодні йшли до цього моменту
часу,
від самого початку до завершення,
по-перше, проект навичок euful
мав три стовпи, три ключові
компоненти, перший стосувався підтримки
ветеринарних шкіл, модернізації змісту
освіти, створення сучасного
навчального середовища  другий
компонент стосується сприяння
професійному вибору та вибору кар’єри
українців покращений доступ до цього, а
третій компонент
стосувався підтримки системних реформ
і ми можемо згадати багато віх,
пов’язаних із визнанням
досягнень української освіти в Європі
розвиток
галузевої освіти на цьому  розробка
професійних стандартів, модернізація
навчальних програм і так далі,
я думаю, ви можете почути ще багато історій
від наших партнерів,
які вже є, і ви можете поділитися
ними,
вони можуть
я думаю, що Ірина Шумік, мабуть,
найбільше розповість вам про
самі ініціативи  і
впровадження
Я дуже впевнений, що Юрій Баленоок
з національного агентства кваліфікацій
також добре може пригадати багато
цікавих моментів, пов’язаних із
підготовкою звіту про самоатестацію
розробкою професійного стандарту Я
хотів би подякувати парламентському
комітету з питань освіти та  ми
можемо пригадати нашу співпрацю,
пов’язану з розробкою нового
законодавства, пов’язаного з ветеринарією, але все ж я вважаю, що
найбільший скарб ще
попереду,
ви знаєте, що будь-яке партнерство стосується в
першу чергу людей, і ми глибоко
вдячні всім партнерам,
які зробили внесок, які присутні
сьогодні чи  офлайн або онлайн, і ми
будемо раді, що ви спілкуєтеся та спілкуєтеся
з
кожним із вас,
ми будемо раді почути будь-які додаткові
рекомендації під час панельних
дискусій
сьогодні, і ви знаєте, що програма навичок eufo
розпочалася також влітку,
і все почалося в ніті  Хаб на Подолі
був присутній тодішній міністр Ханна Навасад,
і була дискусія про
програмні завдання цього, ніхто не мав
чіткого нечіткого розуміння того, як
все буде розвиватися,
так, було розуміння, що це
сприятиме
розвитку освіти та деяким системним реформам,
але  потім прийшла пандемія,
це дуже змінило всю систему
освіти, не тільки діджиталізація
стала помітною,
потрібно було перекваліфікувати
вчителів і магістрів освіти, і
ми, до речі, змогли перекваліфікувати
тисячу сімсот з них,
пам’ятаєте, пряма конференція
наприкінці пандемії ми
змогли зібрати приблизно 150 із вас, у
нас була ця дуже жвава комунікація,
яка надихнула нас рухатися далі,
ніж життя продовжувалося,
і програма розвивалася далі,
поки не було тих, що почалися минулого
лютого, це змінило Україну та українців
міркування, пов’язані з безпекою,
стали головним пріоритетом, виникли
проблеми, пов’язані з відключеннями
та відключеннями світла, і разом з іншими
партнерами ми змогли розробити
пакет екстреної допомоги, в рамках
якого ми змогли допомогти приблизно
300 школам в Україні,
тоді як спочатку ми зосередилися на  сім
регіонів планети,
де війна почалася в країні, ми
поширили практично на всю
країну,
і приблизно в
жовтні 2022 року у нас трапилася
аварія, коли ракета влучила в
будівлю міністерства, і ми з радістю
запропонували
міністерській команді можливість перенести наш
офіс, ми були  ми змогли продовжити нашу
співпрацю завдяки тому, що
приблизно це дорожня карта
програми
минулі віхи, які
ми мали уточнити та переглянути наші
програмні цілі, і дійсно
програма була надзвичайно гнучкою,
що знову забезпечило нам унікальний
досвід
реалізації таких проектів у
складних умовах  умови
одна з унікальних особливостей нашої
програми навичок для молоді полягає в тому, що вона зосереджена на
самих людях
учні вчителі співробітники ми
завжди віддавали пріоритет змінам внесення
змін у життя реальних людей ми
завжди відстоювали європейські цінності
допомога вразливим групам
допомога педагогам
бути в курсі  з новими розробками та
допомогою учням,
так, життя продовжується,
і дозвольте мені поділитися з вами парою
особистих історій,
як ви можете бачити на слайдах, це
історія воєнного періоду,
це час, коли ЗМІ шкодують
Наталію Рібок,
вчительку з  ветеринарна школа в хвилі
вона намагалася пристосуватися до нових викликів і
інспектувати чи будь-що, незважаючи на те, що
ветеринарна школа сама була закрита, але вона
дуже активно займалася розробкою
онлайн-курсів і допомагала їх запускати,
тому ми
полегшили багато показників для  відновити
їхній доступ до своїх студентів, щоб
зберегти їх стабільність і стійкість
Освіта
ми сприяли співпраці з роботодавцями
і змогли допомогти багатьом молодим людям
вона змогла отримати навички
продавця в магазині, і, незважаючи на божевільну
ситуацію, вона була настільки успішною, що
приземлилася  кілька пропозицій роботи після
завершення
ми почули пілотну інформацію про це, і ми
змогли допомогти декільком сотням
молодих людей знайти першу
роботу
або інший випадок це історія
ВПО з Ліми Донецька hombrescally
так, він був ВПО він мав  начебто переїхав
до західного регіону,
знайшовши тимчасовий притулок в одному з тих
закладів, тепер він працює
там і продовжує там працювати, він
сказав, що таким чином він начебто повертає свій борг
перед їхньою спільнотою, яка приймає там,
так, так чи інакше,
це означає, що наш  Програма
завжди була зосереджена на конкретних
окремих людях і на можливостях
запровадження можливостей, що змінюють життя
для них,
тепер, е-е, деякі загальні факти про
досягнення програми,
варто згадати,
близько 300 ветеринарних шкіл
отримали допомогу в рамках програми.
Я думаю, що
немає
ветеринарного персоналу  член, який ніколи не чув або
ніколи не брав участі в нашій програмі, я
думаю, що наші доповідачі також згадали про
це, і
я хотів би згадати один із, мабуть,
найуспішніших випадків, ініційованих
програмою, він стосувався просування
ветеринарної медицини в цілому, покращення її іміджу
регіонах України
ми хотіли, щоб
система ветеринарної медицини створювала
певні
можливості для молодих людей, які
були б видимими та були б нежиттєздатними,
і я думаю, що принаймні половина
жителів України мали змогу почути
оновлені новини про
те, що
можливості
стали можливими  під час
співпраці з Партнерами ми створили
багато онлайн-контенту, ми створили нові
онлайн-інструменти, онлайн-платформу, яка, насамперед,
називається «Освіта та навчання»,
і, безсумнівно, для цього знадобиться більше
інформації та оновлень, але це вже
працює над підвищенням популярності та іміджу
професійної освіти та навчання.
ми підтримували системні реформи
в професійній освіті та навчанні,
незважаючи на пандемію, незважаючи на війну, ми
робили все можливе, щоб
покращити професійні та освітні
стандарти, ми
працювали над спільним звітом, щоб
визнати nqf та конкурувати з
eqf разом із нашими партнерами ми
також працював над іншими компонентами
цієї всеохоплюючої реформи,
так, ледь не забув, один момент,
який стосується всього самого масштабу
програми,
ви можете побачити місця по всій Україні,
де ми проводили наші заходи,
ми бачили, як позначено сім точок регіонів
на карті
ми подолали це обмеження, щоб працювати в
усіх обласних центрах,
і ми змогли провести понад
700 з них, і
ми розглянули гендерний баланс для цього,
і ми
можемо сказати, що більше
000 учасників взяли участь у них,
дуже шкода, що  не кожен наш
партнер чи колега може приєднатися до
цієї події в Києві, але деякі з них
онлайн і стежать за цією подією,
ну
я хотів би скористатися цією можливістю та
подякувати всім нашим
колегам, перш за все нашим місцевим командам,
які підтримали нашу діяльність
ми співпрацювали з багатьма вчителями, експертами з
бізнесу
та представниками компанії.
Дякую,
ви принесли частинки свого досвіду, частинки
своєї душі,
ви зробили внесок в успіх
нашої програми та екскурсії. Найбільший
скарб того, що
особливі речі дістаються нашим партнерам-виконавцям,
неможливо переоцінити
внесок  нашими фінськими колегами,
які модернізували наші навчальні курси,
зокрема колегам з eduffy, ми
хочемо подякувати польській солідарності за
фінансування відділу освіти в Хані,
шановні колеги, разом, спільними
зусиллями ми зробили внесок у
розкриття потенціалу майбутнього
українця
та
мене  Я все ще хотів би згадати регіони, яким
вони зараз не підпорядковуються, військово-цивільні
адміністрації,
вони були дуже активними у своїй
співпраці з нами,
залученими до місцевих громад, щоб
все відбувалося, щоб
все йшло до чорнобривців, щоб
життя
області
ця програма стала можливою завдяки
Joint  знову зусилля з боку ЄС
Фінляндія Польща
Німеччина Естонія
Я хотів би подякувати
вашій делегації в Україні за її величезний
внесок без вашої підтримки дорога
Віро багато чого не станеться
Я хотів би
подякувати всім дипломатичним представництвам
держав-партнерів
та  їхні колеги,
я хотів би знову вітати вас на цих
заключних заходах програми,
я щиро запрошую вас продовжити
обговорення результатів і перспектив
на майбутнє пізніше, велике спасибі [
Оплески] [
Музика]
дякую
[Музика]
[  Оплески]
дякую
[Музика]
Я думаю,
гм,
ви змогли пригадати події
недавнього минулого, дякую за відео,
яке допомогло нам із тим, що
ми змогли заглибитися в проект,
і багато чого було зроблено
для  пишайтеся онлайн-
курсами Зустрічі онлайн офлайн
розробка стандартів
допомога ветеринарним школам
для забезпечення функціонування у ваших
обставинах
Я дуже сподіваюся, що це те,
що залишиться після
програми, і це буде розвиватися далі,
оскільки Дмитро згадав, що багато речей буде
вдосконалено
там  це гарне слово сталого розвитку
англійською, це те, чого ми хотіли б
досягти в усіх проектах, за які проголосували
донори чи партнери, а не лише в цьому, ми
хочемо, щоб ці результати залишилися в
країні, і ми збираємося говорити про те,
що
Ірина Шумік має  було згадано повсюдно,
і я думаю, що це правильний
час, щоб запросити її на подіум, щоб дізнатися
більше про поточний стан цієї
освіти, які виклики,
які тенденції та як це можна
або потрібно відповідати  тож дозвольте мені
представити групу учасників дискусії,
тому що ласкаво просимо на посаду радника з
питань освіти в посольстві Фінляндії
освіта
[музика]
голова nqa
Лілія займається
ветеринарами та міжнародним
співробітництвом у Національній службі зайнятості
експерт із навичок молоді та заступник
міністра освіти
у 2015–2019 роках.
[Музика]
Я думаю, Пабло, це трохи про
стійкість, враховуючи попередні
зусилля в цьому напрямку, і я думаю,
що ми можемо почати знову, е-е, ми
збираємося обговорити і подивитися, чи
є у вас запитання щодо  учасників дискусії,
ви можете їх записати, і це буде
зібрано та доставлено нам пізніше,
можливо, у вас є якісь думки, якими ви
хотіли б поділитися, а тим часом ми поговоримо
про те,
що саме відбувається з освітою,
як ми можемо
залучити нових здібних людей до
ринки праці в Україні, щоб утримати їх, щоб
переконатися, що вони
беруть участь у відновленні України,
ви знаєте,
з мого досвіду модерування, це
багато подій,
також пов’язаних із освітніми соціальними питаннями,
для мене це все ще перший раз, коли я
модерую тему професійної
освіти та навчання  і я не можу дочекатися,
щоб почути більше про контекст, щоб
зрозуміти, наскільки
це важливо, тому що щоразу, коли ви
приїжджаєте за кордон, скажіть Німеччині
ключові банери, які ви можете побачити
там, про професійно-технічну
освіту та вибір кар’єри та
деякі справді практичні вакансії синіх комірців,
які широко рекламуються, ви можете пройти
автобаном і побачити багато таких оголошень,
і це говорить про те, наскільки затребувані ці
професії синього кольору,
так,
це говорить про ступінь уваги в
країні, тому що вони точно
розуміють, як  це важливо для
економічного розвитку, і я дуже
сподіваюся, що ми побачимо щось подібне
в Україні, тож дозвольте нам
ще раз розповісти про них більше,
будь ласка, запишіть свої запитання чи
коментарі, і це буде зібрано та
надіслано на трибуну Direct
і ми йдемо
на перше запитання до Лілії,
коли ми говоримо про освіту Загальне та
місце канікул і навчання
конкретно це стосується
Я б зрозумів, що відбувається на
ринку праці Що відбувається Які
тенденції Що змінилося на
початку війни Що з ВПО  і так
далі,
яка ситуація на
ринку праці, які професії користуються найбільшим
попитом і як юнацькі навички
допомогли вам визначити
ці потреби,
і дорогі друзі, дякую вам за
запрошення на цей останній захід
проекту навичок UFO, який ви  цілком правильно, що
державні служби зайнятості є ключовим
гравцем,
коли йдеться про регіональні
ринки праці та національний ринок праці, і,
звичайно, ми проводимо дослідження ринків праці,
проект з вивчення
ринку праці в Україні розпочався ще у
2020 році, коли ми
розділив
загальну Україну на 10 регіонів
і вивчив
ринок праці
в будівельному секторі,
враховуючи потенційну потребу
в будівельних професіях для
відновлення України,
ми отримали розуміння, які професії є найбільш
потрібними
для роботодавців у цьому Романі
правильно сказав, що ми  маємо
багато інструментів на центральному рівні, які
дозволяють нам покращити професійну підготовку
для найбільш затребуваних професій,
вони, хм,
ті, хто шукає роботу. Я
повинен сказати, що у нас є така категорія,
очі ВПО, які потребують перекваліфікації, у нас
занадто багато безробітних, які  перебувають
на обліку в службі зайнятості, які
мають вищу освіту і зараз їм
потрібна перепідготовка
[музика]
міжпрофесійні
професії і
найбільша потреба в водіях
інструкторах водіях
сільськогосподарських фермах
і підприємствах їм потрібні такі
професії також зварювальники
хм дуже потрібні на
ринку праці і це  є постійний попит
у нашому
секторі працевлаштування,
тоді є великий попит у
системі логістики
на співробітників,
їм потрібні водії
для логістики всередині України та всіх
тих професій, які потребують
уваги на національному рівні та з боку
держави, і ми повинні зробити все
можливе
оновити та перекваліфікувати наших IDPs, і ми
розуміємо, що ці професійні
професії вони дуже популярні та
дуже затребувані. Дякую за це
знайомство з тими
професіями, які найбільше потрібні,
і
це не тільки професії, які
сьогодні затребувані, ми пізніше  обговоріть,
що буде потрібно завтра
[Музика]
розкажіть нам, яке ваше бачення, які
професії можуть знадобитися на завтра
ви, хлопці, о, яка
особливість
професійного
навчання в Україні в будь-якій країні, я
думаю, в Європі це те, що ми  ми дуже
сміливі в плані експериментів,
ми не боїмося просто
випробувати щось нове, щоб спробувати щось
нове
протягом останніх чотирьох років,
гм,
я мав нагоду спостерігати, як ця
система трансформувала, як
був підхід людей у ​​цій системі  зміна
на початку
сектор професійного навчання був не
дуже готовий до змін, але
ми команда сміливих людей, і
ми хотіли
не просто навчати молодих людей
у ​​відпустці, але
ми також повинні надавати допомогу
дорослим у будь-якому віці, які потребують
перепідготовка, можливо, деякі професії вони
просто
зникають, наприклад, листоноша,
професія листоноші,
ця професія майже вмирає, тепер вона
йде в минуле, будуть
роботи, які доставлятимуть
пошту, і вони зараз роблять в
Естонії, наприклад, це означає, що у нас
є  розробити нову
систему професійних стандартів на
національному рівні, і це означає, що ця
система стає ближчою до
ринку праці, це найважливіше
для нас, ми хочемо
зробити цю систему максимально наближеною до життя та
все ще близькою до вимог
Ринок праці настільки можливий, що
хм хм
відчуває будь-яке
скорочення, наприклад, минулого року,
наприклад, ми затвердили стандарт для
саперів, стандарт підготовки для саперів,
а сьогодні ми розуміємо, що
доступне нове обладнання для розмінування, і ми цього
року ми хм ми маємо переглянути  ці
стандарти підготовки для саперів базуються на
новинках у цій сфері, і ми повинні
забезпечити цю гнучкість на національному
рівні, а потім і на регіональному рівнях,
звичайно, немає нічого ідеального, але
ми можемо побачити позитивні
зміни у всій системі на даний момент
Тепер моє запитання до Міни
:
будь ласка, скористайтеся своїми навушниками
та який
досвід Фінляндії
ви можете запропонувати використати в Україні,
тому що ми знаємо, що тонка
освітня система є однією з найкращих
у світі в Європі, напевно, тому в цьому
це IIT  освіта, що ви
пропонуєте використати чи, можливо, якісь
підходи, які можна використовувати в нашій
країні, будь ласка, ми знаємо, що
я дуже радий, що можу розповісти вам
трохи про наш підхід, але я
думаю, що насправді це питання слід
задати  Ірина, яка нещодавно відвідала
Фінляндію, тому було б дуже цікаво
дізнатися, як вона відчуває, що ми, е-е,
добре, е-е,
забезпечуємо для України, але я б сказав, що
Ірина вже говорила про е-е, зміни,
і раніше ми чули, наприклад, Деніел
Буше з TI сказав  щоб говорити про
гнучкість як про ключ, і я думаю, що
це не той підхід, я б сказав, що
фінський підхід, це підхід, який
ми всі повинні розуміти, чи
перебуваємо ми в Фінляндії, в Україні чи
Німеччині, але ми повинні розуміти, що
ми не бачили майбутнього,
коли я приїхав до Києва в лютому 2020 року,
я не міг уявити, що ковіт
означав для України, Фінляндії та світу,
тоді ми не бачили, що наближається війна, я маю на увазі, що
ми говорили про війну, але ми
не  справді вірю, що Росія
була б такою ж божевільною, якою вона виявилася, тому я
вважаю, що, оскільки ми не можемо бачити майбутнє,
ми повинні готуватися до різних
сценаріїв майбутнього, тому у нас повинна
бути система, яка може швидко реагувати
і так, як я  думаю, що те, чого
ми можемо навчитися завдяки тому, що ми
застосували, це те, що ми повинні служити
як окремим особам, так
і суспільству,
що означає, що гнучкість має
різні форми та різні причини, які ми повинні мати
можливість служити учням
з особливими освітніми потребами, які
ми також маємо  щоб обслуговувати людей з
обмеженими можливостями, і ми знаємо, що
в Україні зростає кількість учнів з обмеженими можливостями,
це означає, що ми повинні мати систему,
яка розуміє важливість
модульності, яка розуміє
індивідуальні плани навчання,
тому гнучкість є ключовою  до всього,
я так думаю, у Фінляндії це означає,
що раз на рік ви можете подати заявку,
молоді люди зазвичай подають заявку на
ветеринарну освіту,
але насправді ви також можете приєднатися цілий
рік, тому це не лише раз на рік,
можливо, ви не зможете  подати заявку
з будь-якої причини, інакше ви можете не
розуміти, що це може бути
ваш життєвий шлях, тому учні можуть подавати документи
також протягом року,
і останнє, що я хотів би
сказати, це те, що ветеринар у Фінляндії
надає освіту не лише для
Молоде покоління, але також і
для дорослих учнів, і я думаю, що
це також те, як розробити систему,
яка може
обслуговувати як дорослих учнів, так і
молодь одночасно в економічно
ефективній якісній манері. Дякую, так,
дуже дякую,
пізніше поставлю додаткові запитання.
Так, дякую,
добре, зараз ми обговорюємо гнучкість
і
здатність цієї системи бути
стійкою до всіх змін у житті
в контексті гнучкості У мене є
запитання до Юрія
гнучкість і стандарти, як ці дві
речі координуються між  один одного та
хм,
чи чого ви навчилися в ЄС щодо
навичок, чи ви
вирішили застосувати, можливо, нові підходи, щоб
бути більш
гнучкими
тощо.
Доброго дня, я хотів би сказати, що
результатом цього проекту є 29
кваліфікаційних
центрів і
кваліфікації  які я призначив для
вивчення в цих центрах
270 професійних стандартів і
178 заявок на нові професійні
стандарти та 59 заявок на перегляд
старих професійних стандартів це
про гнучкість і адаптивність до
нових викликів нашого часу
два тижні тому я мав шанс  відвідати
національну
конференцію національних
координаторів спеціальностей VT у
Брюсселі, і ну, на цій конференції я
нагадав, що в травні було 120
повітряних атак Aries на Київ і
ракети, які є високотехнологічними продуктами,
потребують дуже високих навичок або використовуються, і
це  також для відбиття цих атак нам
також потрібен був висококваліфікований
персонал, і це був запит Національної
гвардії
щодо професійної підготовки, яка
дозволила нам навчати людей військовим
професіям, і, до речі, це
також стосується гнучкості, а потім думати
про майбутнє після відновлення вовни  ми
розуміємо, що нам знадобиться багато
професій, різних ударних інструментів, і ми
повинні почати сьогодні, тому
11 липня ми запускаємо
новий курс для розробників
професійних стандартів,
тому що ми розуміємо, що без
вимог до якості стандарти якості для
професійно-технічних  ми не
зможемо підвищити ефективність навчання за допомогою цієї
системи. Ми говоримо про робітничі
професії, ми повинні
говорити одночасно про глибину
цього.
Я згадав, що він тут новачок, я
знаю, що він не правий,
тому що працює  у цифровому
міністерстві цифровізації вони
розробили цей цифровий компонент для всіх
професій, тоді, кажучи,
ми прагнемо стати членами
Європейського Союзу, ми розуміємо, що маємо
відповідати
всім професійним стандартам або
боржникам, яких ми будемо  потрібно відповідати
енергозберігаючим технологіям, наприклад,
енергозберігаючі вікна будинків
тощо, щоб мати можливість відповідати цьому, нам
потрібні висококваліфіковані
будівельники та робоча сила щодо
швидкості, з якою люди
готуються до ринку праці,
кваліфікаційні центри  повинні бути в змозі
швидко реагувати на мінливий
ринок праці, щоб задовольнити вимоги
людей, які відчувають, що вони повинні пристосувати
свої навички до нових потреб
ринку праці
також професійні
стандарти вони формуються ринком
ми маємо
прогнозувати, що потрібно  і працювати
системно,
так, дякую, це важливо, але
знову виникає питання, про які
саме професії ми говоримо, чи
збираєтеся ви це розкривати, тому що
так, ми більше не можемо їздити верхи,
добре, я скажу це так, ми
цього не розуміємо  війна поставила
перед нами надзвичайні виклики, і звичайний
компонент у цій війні, за моєю
особистою оцінкою,
це 50-55 відсотків,
решта стосується
інфовоєнної інформаційної безпеки
українського народу, наприклад,
Національна служба спеціального
зв'язку та захисту інформації, яку
вони вже розробили  шість займають
стандарти для
позначення способів
захисту мережевої інформації тощо,
і вони працюють над ще 14
професійними стандартами,
які встановлюватимуть вимоги до
відповідних навчальних програм
і відповідної освіти,
тому, коли вони говорять про системного
адміністратора, це зовсім інша
річ порівняно з тим, що ми мали 10 років
Ви знаєте, 20 років тому
офіцери зв’язку в армії приносили вам
ті дротові телефони і так далі,
і насправді це було повно вантажівок,
тепер у них електронне обладнання та
вимоги зовсім інші,
далі я підтримую колегу з
міністерства освіти  коли вона говорила
про електрогазозварювальників,
ми відзначили багато таких
кваліфікаційних центрів, вибачте,
і ми зробили це для багатьох секторів, які
зараз перебувають на передовій, поблизу тієї
операції Харкінса зі списками тощо, тому
це важливо,
коли люди щось роблять, хоча
коли я відкриваю там кваліфікаційні центри,
це означає, що вони вірять у те, що
станеться в Україні, вони вірять у
майбутнє, і це інформація з відкритих джерел, яку
ви можете знайти,
ми, ви знаєте, як акваріум, ми
абсолютно прозорі, ви можете перейти до нашого
електронні ресурси, щоб знайти кожну
інформацію, і всі бачать її,
лайкають і діляться нею. Ласкаво просимо,
добре чути,
а якщо говорити про прифронтові райони та
території, які, тим не менше,
активно залучені, я пам’ятаю
наш проект із моїм курсом,
і ми мали більше ніж  200 людей з
усієї України приєдналися онлайн, у нас були люди
також від її сина,
це був час, коли вони сиділи
в окупації, але їм вдалося якось
підключитися щотижня люди
хотіли вчитися, і вони твердо вірять,
що її сина буде звільнено
справді
надихнув багатьох людей. Я пам’ятаю
цю пані Наталю, у неї були проблеми з
підключенням, але вона була там.
Я хотів би передати їй щирі вітання,
якщо вона нас почує,
і так, Юрію, дякую, дякую, що
поділився з нами цим
про досягнення,
це  цікаво почути про контексти
та виклики, але давайте не будемо забувати
про
ваші досягнення за майже чотири роки щодо навичок чи знаєте
ви, чи знаєте ви, якісь досягнення,
хотів би поділитися протягом усього часу
щось, що справді сприяло змінам,
запроваджувало зміни чи
щось на краще, дозвольте нам  почніть
з Арени і переходьте один за одним,
досить важко згадати лише
пару з них, тому що ви знаєте,
я пам’ятаю, що чотири роки тому було
справді страшно взяти
на себе відповідальність за
всю цю голландську реформу,
завдання якої  робота над проектом
повністю відповідає нашим планам, що
ми справді
готові з точки зору
реформ разом із
Європейським освітнім фондом,
і коли ми планували, ми думали,
що це може бути впорано,
потім ми зрозуміли, що ні, це
страшно, і це виклик, але  тоді ви
знаєте, що ми звикли щось робити, навіть
незважаючи на страх, і з цього
все почалося,
але я вважаю, що справді великим подарунком на день народження
для мене є той факт, що
образ обличчя системи ветеринара зміна, якою
ми більше не є
боюся речей, пов’язаних із цим, я пам’ятаю,
що для перших відео ми
шукали
когось для участі, учня, який
би пішов і зацікавився,
а потім ми створили ці відео на основі
перших результатів, і ми побачили, що діти
все більше цікавляться,
а потім ми  приєдналися майстри навчання та
вчителі, а потім деякі ветеринарні школи, які
вивчали міжнародний досвід
Фінляндії та Естонії, люди все більше
почали розуміти, що все
можливо, якщо ви щось робите, і
це сприяло зміні загального
іміджу системи, тому це, мабуть,
один із  найкращі досягнення ще одна
річ, про яку варто згадати, це зміна
підходів,
коли мова йде про велику систему, ви знаєте, що
коли ви починаєте зміни, ви
завжди почуєте, як хтось каже,
чому
щось змінюється, ви знаєте, що ви працюєте в хорошому
стані, чому ви покращуєте,
але потім, мабуть,
усе  у нас або у багатьох із нас є внутрішня
дитина, яка хоче змін,
це частина дослідника в мені
в науці, ти завжди хочеш якихось змін,
і по-третє, мені подобається, як
проект допоміг нам стати
командою,
командою однодумців
люди, я не думаю, що Петро та
інші мої колеги, вони пам’ятають, коли
ми вибирали пілотні регіони, у нас було багато
інших регіонів, які не були б включені,
вони відчували б незадоволення, і я
пам’ятаю, як я казав, що ми не можемо,
ви знаєте, знайти більше регіонів для роботи
тому що ми могли возитися з цифрами,
цифрами, щоб заробити більше,
і Олексій мав рацію, коли сказав, що,
незважаючи на ковід, незважаючи на війну,
ми поступово розширювалися,
ми охопили набагато більше територій, і
це створило більшу команду, і я думаю, що
це  мабуть, найбільше досягнення
для мене
це я не збираюся розповідати про низку
подій чи учасників, але це
про системні зміни
так, дякую,
дорога Міно,
три
три успіхи проекту навичок НЛО,
я думаю, що вони набагато більші успіхи, ніж
три  але зараз я, звичайно,
навмисне вибрав успіхи,
які були досягнуті нашими
фітнес-експертами, тож вибачте за моїх
польських, німецьких та естонських
колег,
але я хотів би сказати,
що це важливо.  завжди
пам’ятати про роль вчителів і
керівників шкіл, коли ми впроваджуємо будь-яку
реформу чи повсякденну освіту, тому я вважаю,
що підготовка вчителів і
навчання в шкільному менеджменті, які були надані
проектом у рамках
проекту, були дуже важливими,
тому що вони дійсно  відіграють ключову роль як
агенти змін у цій реформі, вони роблять
щоденну якісну освіту,
тому, щоб почати з проекту, визначені
компетенції, якими
повинні володіти вчителі та керівники шкіл, щоб
покращити реформу ветеринарної медицини,
тому ці компетенції включають,
наприклад, коучингову співпрацю з  трудове
життя, співробітники та промисловість зміна
управлінських навичок і прибирання ветеринара Я
хотів би сказати кілька слів про цей
скринінг, як тільки у мене буде можливість. Я
вважаю, що навчання віт є дуже важливим,
тому ми, я думаю, повинні запитати, як професійна
освіта та підготовка можуть насправді
сприяйте сталому розвитку,
ділячись та застосовуючи сучасні
знання та практики зі студентами,
які стануть майбутніми фахівцями у
своїх галузях,
тому, як уже згадував колега, я
маю на увазі, що є багато-багато
питань, пов’язаних із
прибиранням  і перевірте, наприклад, які
матеріали можна використовувати при будівництві нових будинків
чи
ремонті старих, чи який вуглецевий
слід різних матеріалів і чому
це важливо,
чи які альтернативні джерела
електроенергії доступні сьогодні, що є
більш безпечними для навколишнього середовища  або,
наприклад, як зменшити хімічне навантаження в
салонах краси, тож є багато-багато
запитань, пов’язаних із
нинішнім і майбутнім суспільством та Україною,
що насправді професійно-технічна освіта та
підготовка та вчителі можуть внести
зміни, якщо вони повністю розуміють, що
це має значення
Отож, другий, який я хотів би сказати,
це розроблення стандартів і навчальних програм,
ми всі розуміємо,
що для того, щоб мати якісну освіту,
ми повинні мати сучасні стандарти, а
також навчальну програму, якщо ми цього не робимо, це
дуже  важко реагувати на потреби
суспільства та мінливі потреби
суспільства,
отже, потреби ринку праці
дуже актуальні, як це
також зазначалося раніше.
Тож у цій рамках
експерти Phoenix підтримали розробку 20
освітніх стандартів і 20 навчальних програм
ми розуміємо, що 20 – це дуже мало в
цифрах, але це було зроблено таким чином, щоб
навчити українців, як цей процес
можна зробити краще, щоб він
враховував потреби суспільства
потреби робочого життя  і т.д. і т.п., тож я
б сказав, що справа не стільки в
кількості, скільки в
процесі спільного навчання та певному
збільшенні спроможності українських
акторів на місцях робити це
незалежно в майбутньому,
тому справа в капітальних можливостях
будівництво дуже багато
у виданні розвитку для
компаній профілі були зроблені
враховуючи триваючу війну
і післявоєнну відбудову, тому я наводжу вам
приклади, наприклад, ремонт і
будівництво будівель і приміщень
і будівництво невеликих будівель це
був один з  їх ремонт і
будівництво пошкоджених інженерних комунікацій та
деякої іншої інфраструктури, утилізація відходів
і реабілітація навколишнього середовища,
дуже важлива тема сьогодні, ми
розуміємо, що ця нещасна
війна завдала стільки шкоди
неймовірній природі України, а
також забезпечуючи соціальні моделі та
супутню підтримку  особам, які
отримали фізичні чи морально-психічні
травми та вади під час війни, це
теж те, що ми повинні враховувати на будь-якому
рівні освіти,
і останнє, що я
хотів би відзначити, це 20
онлайн коротких  ці курси були
розроблені після того, як
почалася війна, тому було зрозуміло, що потрібно
щось зробити, але те, до чого
можна легко отримати доступ, де б
вони не були Учні, чи вони
в Україні, чи вони в інших
країнах,
і я хотів би  сказати, що цифри
кількості учнів, які зареєструвалися,
показують, що така діяльність
також була
потрібна, тож на кінець березня було
вже понад 19
000 реєстрацій на ці курси та
понад 12 500 сертифікатів, виданих
з них, тому я  вважаю, що це
дуже конкретні дії, які
були виконані, ви також можете назвати їх досягненнями.
Я вважаю, що досягнення полягає в тому, що
нам вдається продовжувати підтримувати цю
реформу, незважаючи на труднощі. Дякую, дякую, так, дякую,
велике спасибі
аплодисменти,
це наш Енерджайзер,
Юрій, що б ви сказали про ключові
досягнення проекту,
ви знаєте, що nqf nka
навряд чи пам’ятає своє існування
без цього проекту ЄС для навичок,
тому що ми виникли в 2019 році
в
листопаді ми стали
юридичними особами  і за короткий час на
нас прийшла війна, тож ми вижили
через випробування на розгром
у наш зелений період існування завдяки
нашому спілкуванню та співпраці
з молодими навичками, щоб процвітати,
тому що ми розділяли розуміння
важливості кваліфікації,
особливо на основі  Досвід ЄС
вони надають велике значення цьому, і якщо ви
хочете жити, виживати та розвиватися в
ЄС, ми повинні розробити
систему, яка була б адаптована до
вимог ЄС, ми повинні мати можливість говорити
спільною мовою,
зокрема в термінах
систем кваліфікації, які ми маємо, тому
одним із перших кроків для нас було
отримати якомога більше досвіду щодо
цього, і ми кілька разів відвідали
ваші країни-члени,
ми відвідали деякі спеціальні кваліфікаційні
центри, ми спілкувалися з
міністрами  навчальні навчальні центри
тощо. Можливо, я зможу надати вам більше
інформації під час перерви на каву, але
важливо те, що ми спробували
засвоїти
всі найкращі практики, які ми змогли використати в
ЄС, і,
крім того, ми
змогли впровадити всі законодавчі
норми
які регулюють діяльність nqa, ми зробили
все можливе, і це було зроблено
завдяки нашій співпраці з
проектом навичок eufu, і ми вдячні йому
за це.
Другий пункт стосується лібералізації
певних процесів
і
капелюха перед українським парламентом за те, що
вони розглянули перспективи
Розвиток людського капіталу та один із
співавторів законодавства та
Розвиток людського капіталу
Юлія Коваль тут дякуємо і за це,
тож цей закон започаткував належний
розвиток кваліфікаційних стандартів
у країні, це важливо, тому що
ні стілець, ні ключ А чи фургон
заступник міністра хтось такий
не може визначити вимоги, скажімо,
Тернер
або я не знаю, металіст,
уряд має просто стежити за
належним виглядом процедури для
виконання вимог, але м’ясо до
кісток потрібно додати,
але ринок і
е-е  Ветеринарні школи зараз масово подають заявки
на nqia, вимагаючи
кваліфікації для різних типів
освіти, як-от неформальний тип
індикації, і ми бачимо, що багато
кваліфікаційних центрів
все частіше відкриваються у ветеринарних школах
також поблизу лінії фронту,
коли nqa було створено,
уряд змінився  законодавство для
приведення рівня нашої
кваліфікації
в рамках nkf у відповідність до європейської
кваліфікаційної рамки, яка забезпечила
краще розуміння
це про загальну мову ви знаєте, як ви
вимірюєте ви знаєте певні товари,
наприклад, у кілограмах або тоннах багато в чому
нам потрібно  мати спільні терміни
під час прийняття рішень щодо чиїхось
кваліфікацій, і ми досягли величезного
прогресу, коли порівняли наш nqf
з eqf
наступний
етап у цьому третьому пункті.
Я не знаю, чи я все ще встигав,
тому терпіть  будь ласка,
тепер ми створили CP,
який є національним координаційним центром
для співпраці з ikeaf, і
завтра у нас буде представник AC,
ми обговоримо точний
графік,
коли ми збираємося порівняти та завершити
порівняння нашого nqf із  eqf
це відкриє для нас нові двері,
і важливо
сказати, що навіть робоча група з
конкурентоспроможної nqf мала нашого великого друга з
Ангоравеї серед своїх членів,
і звіт був підписаний
Європейською комісією та міністром
освіти і науки України, і це
третє досягнення, яким можна пишатися в
рамках нашої співпраці, тож я
сподіваюся, що навички для
проекту відновлення будуть все ж важливими
та ще більш доречними, враховуючи
виклик, який нинішній час
показує нам, дякую,
дякую Лілія
три хвилини
ах, цей проект
зробив
найбільший внесок у наших
викладачів у
закладах професійної освіти,
інвестуючи в людський капітал, ви
зможете
відновити всю країну протягом
останніх трьох років, наші
викладачі мали можливість
підвищити свій професійний рівень, щоб
оволодіти вашими
навичками та конкурувати  і отримати нові
компетенції
рівень Державної служби зайнятості.
Можу сказати, що нам вдалося
досягти
синергії
в
розумінні необхідних змін для
ринків праці, і в результаті цього ми
пропонуємо внести зміни до
законодавства, які Поправка пропонує, що
зміни були розроблені разом  з
роботодавцями та
центрами професійної підготовки
пропонується більше
навчання для ВПО, і ВПО стали
важливим компонентом у цьому
проекті.
Кваліфікаційні центри є дуже важливим
ключовим моментом.
Важливо не просто пропонувати
професійні навички,
а пропонувати їх тим, хто найбільше
вони дійсно потрібні, це IDPS, і
IDPS
досить часто потрібно отримати
сертифікат про належну
професійну підготовку, і в цьому аспекті
наш проект виявився дуже корисним,
дякую,
Пабло,
наскільки я розумію,
ти
зробив внесок у проект, коли
працював у міністерстві  так, ми
готували проект, поки його
реалізовували інші люди,
хм, це
фінальна подія, але кожен українець
пам’ятає відомий вірш Лєни Костенко про те,
що кожен фінальний
хм фактично означає початок і
[Музика]
хм
на етапі підготовки в  У міністерстві
ми чітко розуміли,
що
професійне навчання відрізняється від
середньої шкільної освіти, тому що ви
працюєте,
щоб
задовольнити конкретний попит конкретних
роботодавців, і
ви зрозумієте, що кожна професія
потрібна в певній кількості
працівників, і третій
важливий аспект  це освіта для
дорослих не лише для молоді й
дорослих, вони потребують
короткострокового навчання й дуже конкретного,
можливо, навчання, і
на самому початку, дивлячись на
бюджет у 54
мільйони,
ми порівнюємо ці 54
мільйони, надані на  Україна проти 30
мільйонів, наданих набагато меншій Грузії,
ми закликаємо переглянути цю цифру,
і
тепер, дивлячись на результати, ми розуміємо,
що це був
правильний підхід,
гм, я спробую говорити коротше, ніж
12 хвилин,
так, у нас є роботодавці,
але дивлячись на наші
ми чітко бачимо, що дві третини
з них – це молоді люди,
майже підлітки, і лише одна третина –
дорослі, і, звичайно, ці
молоді
люди, яким вони користуються своїм правом
вибору професії, вони
фактично
реалізують своє конституційне право
вибирати, але хто має координувати, щоб
це конституційне право
використовувалося на благо суспільства, і ми
маємо запропонувати навчання, яке здатне
підготувати
найкращих професіоналів,
і
це був лише контекст, щоб сказати,
можливо, найважливішу річ
у
міністерстві  попередній попередній семестр у наших
дискусіях була Ліла Гріневич,
ми обговорювали серцеві компоненти,
м’які компоненти та м’які компоненти –
усі вони дуже корисні, але
навчання важких
компонентів – це основи, але
отримання нових
навичок, м’які навички завжди є, це
завжди дає  можливість для людини
змінити сферу діяльності, щоб звільнитися з поточної
роботи, і
хоча важкий компонент освіти
є наші позитивні практики, наші центри
передового досвіду
гм [
Музика]
ну, вони з’являться в майбутньому, поки
що ми їх не бачимо, але ми все ще сподіваємось
що
після війни ці центри врешті-решт
з’являться, а тепер ближче до відповіді
на ваше запитання
минулого тижня у
нас був величезний
фестиваль професійної підготовки в Ліві, і
міністр Елізабет відвідала фестиваль,
і
наші дискусії тривали
на першому  Міністр
зазначив, що на сьогодні
головним пріоритетом для країни є
сфера безпеки та все, що пов’язано
з військовою сферою, а головним
пріоритетом номер два є розвиток
людського капіталу та
розвиток людських навичок,
включаючи професійні навички, а також я
дуже згоден з міністром, коли
він
каже, що Україна врешті-решт отримала
свою високу
суб’єктивність
у міжнародному вимірі,
ну, що ми зробили в проекті
на початку, ми думали про
обласні
ради чи слова про
[музику]
кваліфікації,
і тут нам довелося  подолати радянський
минулий радянський підхід та
ідею про те, що величезні
потреби просто
навчити студентів, а потім
дозволити їм отримати належний сертифікат,
але поступово ми прийшли до
розуміння того, що
якість отриманих нових навичок є
важливою, а компетенції
мають  увійти до системи професійно-технічної
підготовки
ще одна велика річ — мати дуже хорошого
лідера для системи професійно-технічної
підготовки Arena працювала
в цій системі
з повним складом міністрів освіти. Я
вважаю, що це гарна стійкість,
і я думаю, що
багато людей
гм
так, зараз я зацікавлений у професійному
навчанні, і як члени парламенту ми
повинні дозволити людям це робити, і ми
чітко спостерігаємо зростаючий інтерес до
професійного навчання
та дистанційного навчання, а потім
консультацій щодо професійного навчання,
і це найважливіші
речі
сьогодні,
незважаючи на це
той факт, що це заключна
подія, насправді наші колеги ще
не закінчили свою роботу в Україні, і
це
не
крапка, це лише крапка з комою, щоб
сказати, чи
це там, і прочитайте сигнал тривоги,
Віра,
можливо,
ви опишете
перспективи
Я хотів би відповісти на те, що
сказав Пабло Кузьмович
[Музика]
хм,
ми багато працювали над дизайном
проекту, і я пам’ятаю
хм наполягання міністерства щодо належної
структури
проекту,
і сьогодні я маю сказати, що один із
найбільшим досягненням проекту є
зміцнення інституційної спроможності.
Команда, яку ми маємо сьогодні, очевидно,
дуже
потужна, дуже сильна українська
команда, яка була
створена
в результаті цього проекту, тепер
повертаючись до інфраструктурного компоненту,
давайте не забувати про 21 мільйон,
який  потім підтримав
20 мільйонів додатково з
Китаю з Німеччини, які надійдуть
пізніше, і це мудре рішення, тому що
Німеччина, оскільки війна не дозволить
нам використати їх належним чином, а також
Європейський банк реконструкції та
розвитку також приєднався до цього
програму, яка підтримується іншими
донорами, такими як Німеччина, Фінляндія, Польща та
Естонія,
тому Європейський інвестиційний банк
приєднався, тобто ми маємо хороші
ресурси для інфраструктурного
компоненту, але без людей жодна
інфраструктура не стане
функціональною та корисною, тому наш
тут наш людський капітал
основа
нещодавно віце-президент Європейської
комісії правильно сказав, що людський
капітал - це кров для демократії, і
кров є для
ем,
мені дозволили перевірити, чи є у нас
сигналізація в києві,
насправді ми
закінчуємо,
що з майбутнім одним словом
майбутнє  VT одним словом одним словом,
тому що ми повинні піти в притулок
для мене розвиток талантів vt і я
впевнений, що ми побачимо це одним словом
про майбутнє, але одним словом ми не
маємо часу, тому що у нас як тривога
надія на людей і суспільство, велике спасибі, будь ласка,
іноземна
валюта майбутнього
VT означає майбутню
VT, яка успішно конкуруватиме з
вищою освітою,
давайте завантажимо, і
я сподіваюся, що це було корисно, і
вам сподобалося, тепер ми повинні піти до
притулку  тому що, на щастя, є де завгодно,
лише в ключі регіону,
гм,
отримав сигнал тривоги про повітряний наліт, я
хотів би подякувати вам за цю
дискусію, я думаю, що це було цікаво, я
думаю, що це було корисно, і під час нашої
перерви на каву ми зможемо
обговорити більше I  хотів би
оголосити, що
ми матимемо обідню перерву з
12:00 до 13:00 о 14:00, щоб
паралельні сесії розпочиналися на
сесії номер один, яка проходитиме в
цій кімнаті, як і тема: як
Система професійної освіти та навчання змінила регіональний регіональний
рівень
Пабло Хосе є модератором цієї другої
сесії Співпраця між системою ветеринарної медицини
та ринком праці з Алексі
Алексіо буде на рівні M2, щоб
дістатися до
поверху M2 під час запуску, вам слід піднятися на ліфті  будь ласка, подумайте,
що
я думаю, який
сеанс буде цікавий для вас, якщо
вас кілька людей з одного
центру, ви можете розділити свою команду на дві
групи,
візьміть
навушники,
залиште навушники на столах
під час обіду
о 2
[Музика]
ми почнемо о  для сесій
сесія номер три буде проводитися в
цій кімнаті це буде цифровізація
та її роль у розвитку IC vat
та сесія номер чотири забезпечення
якості навчання у відеосистемі
uh
модератор Наталія Самуель ланко яка
буде на другому  поверх
все фактично вказано у вашому
порядку денному,
і
після всіх цих сесій наприкінці
дня ми відсвяткуємо фінальну
подію солодким тортом, а тепер Bon
Appetit, у нас обідня перерва до
13:00, дякую за увагу